i
wanted to pace myself with the show and
i couldn't
i watched it all in one city it was
amazing oh my gosh thank you so much
um the moment we we like the trailer the
beauty i think like everyone at work was
like
what the hell is this we couldn't begin
to describe it
so how how did the idea originated
uh and how do you go about 18 days or
how does that come about um so the idea
was
uh i mean it is a combination of so many
things that i love
um but i the the thematically the idea
from it came from
my experiences when i was in in high
school because i
i really was interested in so many
different things but um i really
i thought that um you know like i grew
up in an environment that was
kind of academically competitive and and
um i thought that i had to kind of
pursue
something more um serious i guess as
a career path so when i was a teenager
and i went into high school
um you know with all these um
with the with them different like ap
classes and stuff lined up um
i i had a scheduling issue and i wound
up in um
show choir unexpectedly and that was um
and while i loved music and musicals i
was not
i was really intimidated by the idea of
performing and so suddenly i was in
an environment that was like very much
like glee where it was you know sparkly
dresses
singing dancing and i was real i felt
really out of my element
um but then i ended up falling in love
with it over the course of that year
despite my initial discomfort and um
that whole experience uh led me to to
really
pursue the arts like i before i thought
that i had to do something
so much more serious but then after
after this experience um
i kept you know i kept doing choir i
kept learning about music
and um and eventually it led me to
pursue animation
because i just really felt like i must
do something creative
um this is this is kind of like it was
finding my
my family or my tribe and so i wanted to
tell the story of
a character who only knew one way of
living or had thought that there was
only one way to do something
who wound up you know somewhere in the
opposite end of the spectrum of
where she you know anything that she
could imagine and um to show how that
could change someone
change a character fundamentally and and
show that there's legitimacy to to
all these things that are outside of you
know like what she thought to be
the only way of existing
right and then how do you um because the
the
the style of the show just the visual
style is so
so unique and so it gives you such a
specific
vibe what were some of the influences in
terms of the
the the visuals and the animation styles
for the show
yeah um so for for the um the visuals we
knew
um it's it's we we almost wanted it to
be like
a character from an entirely different
show winding up it
like from one show winding up in a
different show so we knew that
that visually um these two different
places should look and feel distinct so
we ended up
you know working with two entirely
different animation studios
so we worked with mercury film works um
who's done hilda
and the mickey mouse shorts and and a
lot of other
other uh projects to do the like kind of
more squashy stretchy
centaur world side of things and then we
worked with red dog culture house
which is a korean studio that to do more
of the action um
the the action uh kind of sides of
things so where horse came from
we had you know we had a different
studio training handling that
and the the kind of fun thing was that
as as
we progressed through the project um
these studios had to sometimes kind of
do some things from the other style so
you know it was like it was a really um
fun collaboration and just sort of a
melding and melding creatively
um but but in terms of developing the
visual style
um for uh the centaur world side
it was really kind of a lot of it was
based on um sketchbook drawings and
things like
like that like um i i love drawing um
with marker and
and ink and we wanted it to kind of have
that almost like a bit of a sketchier
um feel to it and for hor
for horse's world to feel more angular
and and a little bit more um
more tactile i guess um
and i think sorry i think earlier you
asked how does one pitch the show as
well and just
to go back to that um yeah like because
it is so
hard to describe there's so many things
going on in it um there's
and so many influences um for pitching
it i just kind of had to
uh work on us you know make making it
kind of making an example of what an
episode would look like
so i ended up doing working with a
couple of artists and doing a storyboard
and
um and i wrote the first four songs for
the so basically i had the first episode
storyboarded out and then um
i um i had like early demos so
basically when i would just be pitching
it and doing all the voices for a
storyboard and showing the panels and
then if we get to a song
i'd press play in my iphone and have
like some piano tracks and just have to
sing
you know sing all the parts um and and
so just pitching through that first
episode
uh was kind of how i pitched it
um and then uh you mentioned the music
so how did that come about
at what point did that became a part of
the show
uh it was always supposed to be a part
of it um i i knew i i really i'm very
passionate about musical theater i love
i love
musicals and um there's there's such a
rich tradition of animated musicals but
they've conventionally been been feature
films and um i really wanted
to have do a series that was a musical
but in a very
you know very committed way where each
episode would have you know at least
three songs and that those songs would
have to be um
narrative or a part of the story um
and so uh from the beginning i wanted it
to be a musical
um but that meant that uh if you know um
for myself and my co-ep uh dominic
vignano who also wrote a lot of the
songs
we would be there in the you know in the
writer's room um
and uh just so we could also be um
just so the songs weren't just sort of
slotted in but so we were there
you know how as the story goes along we
knew
we were going to um you know
make sure that the the story the songs
fit in narratively and that um
we knew these characters inside and out
so that so that we could write them and
they would
they wouldn't feel like just just songs
that were happening for the sake of
having songs
yeah because you mentioned um uh sort of
the history of
uh animated musicals and i found it
really interesting
that this feels more um like
broadway-like uh like where a lot of
like animated uh musicals at least in tv
they're more like for the joke of it or
they're like like short songs
uh just for like the moment we're here
like it's a full-on
musical and even today to the casting uh
how was that like how important was that
for you to have like
proper broadway train actors uh in the
show
um yeah i um we definitely knew that
every one of our
cast members would have to would have to
sing because of just the sheer volume of
music
and um um
we we didn't set out thinking that it
was only going to be broadway people but
we ended up getting a lot of
a lot of amazing um broadway talent um
i think uh i think a lot of theater
actors just
do make great voice actors as well
because um
singer i think a lot of singers can they
can just do a lot of things with their
they have such vocal control
and then they also you know have this
tradition of
just being good actors and and having to
do that on stage so it translates really
well
um when it comes to voice acting and
character acting
so um yeah like when we were um
setting out to do this um we knew
because uh
because a lot of the songs were going to
have like this sort of general musical
theater broadway
vibe that you're talking about that it
was gonna you know like as we as we kept
um we're kind of looking looking at
actors um
it ended up being the direction we sort
of generally went in because
because um they uh they were able to do
so much with the material
um and then even uh i i love that
episode i think this episode seven
is uh it has the the like so many
references to like cats i mean how uh uh
can you talk about like sort of
uh inserting those references to the
show and specifically like
to uh to show that aimed at
younger audiences that may not be as
familiar with that and how
that balance was like yeah um
we we knew when we were writing the
music and kind of setting like
some of the uh are figuring out some of
the set pieces that uh
we would want to reference things but we
never wanted to make like song parodies
or
we didn't want to put anything that was
you know that you would specifically
have to have context for
you know like like pop culture
references specifically like some are
are in there but we wanted to make stuff
that was um
you know like that that theater geeks or
whatever would would
appreciate but also that was that kids
could like you know like people who
weren't as
familiar like um could could still enjoy
and with the cats episode in particular
um yes there are a lot of references to
the musical cats but um but also
um i think i mean i think people just
like cats
as well like as as animals they're just
like hilarious and so there was a lot of
just like
um a lot of just you know um
specific things to to cats as animals
that we that we shoved in there it was
just it was
i think that was one of the most done
one of one of the episodes that um both
both the cast and crew really had a lot
of fun
um playing with and
and speaking of that sort of that that
that makes of a playing to
um kids audience but also adults who may
watch the show i was fascinated by how
by the tonal change at some point like
that that that blend
like that there are really dark moments
in the show
uh that um that still is you know like
he has his silly moments and and and
really funny and perfect moments
uh especially the the the whale
episode um how was
that conversation like when when you
were writing and and making that episode
uh in terms of okay how do we what is
too dark right um
i think we always try to keep keep um
the characters and their emotional
journeys in mind first and foremost so
when we were trying to ride that balance
and it is a delicate
balance um it always came down to
where is the character what is most
appropriate like what are they going
through
and um we found with all the the
different you know places we went to
tonally
um you know it could it could have been
a i mean it was it was a lot right like
in terms of like
the comedy the darkness um kind of the
scarier elements there's a lot going on
and we always felt like
the only thing we could do to kind of
make all of this work
was was to um to really um keep the
characters relationships and their
emotional journeys as
first and foremost and and um
in regards to the the darkness as and um
and our um and kids who might be
watching it i think
um one thing that i've i've always felt
that kids don't like being talked down
to and kids are very aware of reality
too
and so we wanted to make something that
um
had some you know more challenging
themes in it
um but with with um keeping in mind that
kids go through tough things too and
kids
go you know kids are very emotionally
complex and so we wanted something that
they could
they could really have you know go
through all these ups and downs with
these characters
um something i uh adore about the change
like
just how many different uh creatures you
have
playing with with the concept of what a
center is
um were there any that didn't make the
show or what
did you have like a laser like throwing
that how was that like a brainstorming
like
it was so much fun because uh i i mean i
i love
um i love biology when i was when i was
a kid i
you know at some point i wanted to be a
marine biologist as well
and um it's uh i think i love just
it's it's really um like i'm fascinated
with
the biodiversity in our own world um and
so
when we were making this it was just so
much fun to
conceive of everything that could be a
centaur because in this world like
everything down to the bacteria could be
centaurs technically
and then even if you look in the in the
background sometimes you'll see
a mountain and realize that it has you
know arms and legs and hooves
so so i think um for everyone from from
like
the you know the story team to the uh
the designers i think everyone loved
throwing in different things that could
be centaurs
from inanimate objects to like the
leaves and the trees to the to all the
animals
so there's kind of no hard rules or
limits like anything that you could
think of could technically be a centaur
was there anything that that didn't make
the show
um i think there were probably some that
just
uh oh gosh if there was any that
actually didn't make the show there were
a lot of
uh i i kind of wish that we had more
time to explore
uh all the the merre creatures the mer
people you know in episode one of
the whale episode that you referred to
earlier um
because i i think it was would have been
a lot of fun to show more of those i
used to make comics about
the different um more people as well and
just all the different kinds of you know
uh like big and small creatures that
were
so so i kind of wish that we got to show
more of that because we had more that
just didn't make it because of time
right also uh can you talk about the
origin of because i love the
the the recurring bit of the the tiny
horses that they shoot out of
their hooves and how uh they
they are terrified that of their
existence and like this giant creature
that looks like them
very early on when i was still
developing um you know like one of the
first things we did was uh
me and a couple of writers were just
kind of brainstorming like okay what are
the like the dumbest spell balls these
guys could have because
because um i think one of the things we
wanted to do with the magic was to show
that a lot of the centaurs didn't use
them for anything purposeful it was just
for things that like why would this
exist
and um a writer uh my friend hannah
hannah friedman
um we were coming up with the names you
know things like handsome for eight
seconds just these really
names of these all these spells um i
think she pitched one of them as being i
can shoot tiny versions of myself from
my hooves
and that was um and that one just stuck
we just we laughed so much and i started
drawing out the visuals for it
and as i did i was thinking i would
realize that
whatever you know like this would be
like birthing new life
and that it you know like we just
imagine there would be a moment of
existential horror so it just became a
thing
that we had we had um that just stuck
and and so we had them do this
repeatedly
um but it was it was something that was
conceived at the very beginning in
development and we just always
you know like found different ways to
insert it in there because it was such a
bizarre idea
i've been always like fascinated by by
the movement towards more
uh serialization in in in cartoons
and especially in recent years so as
that and
[Music]
the show has like a unique blend like uh
each episode his own thing but also like
he has a
a narrative arc uh was that a part of
the
initial uh concept or did that come in
later how was that like
um that was also part of the the initial
concept um
i uh and um it's interesting how it
relates
to the music as well because we're sort
of thinking of it like
if you have a season it could be almost
like the season like its own album but
then each episode could also be like
their own mini chapters or albums as
well
and um uh yeah so we were thinking about
it in relation to the music but also
um i i really wanted it to to be um
something that had
um um like
a just a feeling of just that kind of
fairy tale quality just being a bigger
story
um and uh i i
really loved um growing up i loved
things like i love all puppets you know
like the muppets
and all of that are a big influence but
um but other
like kinds of like henson projects like
um like
you know like labyrinth and dark crystal
things that had like you know a lot of
different things tonally going on but
that were these kinds of
cool bigger stories the neverending
story all of that
um i wanted something that really just
kind of
was you know felt like it was a big
bigger continuous story um
lastly i know you probably can't say
much about the future of the show
but is there anything uh from this
season that you would really hope
uh to explore further in uh in a
possible season two or anything
yeah um i mean i i think after
establishing this world
um i would love to you know kind of take
it to different
different places kind of meet different
centaurs find different communities that
we haven't
um haven't met yet and kind of areas
that we haven't explored
um but but also um i i really want to
uh show more of the the lore and the
backstory or what you know like we've
alluded to a lot of like what's been
going on here why there's so much
darkness in addition to all the
um the absurdity of the show um so
getting kind of exploring more of the
history of it
is something that i'd love to do now
that you mentioned that uh
let um do you mentioned like the
the big like fantasy movie that sort of
inspired you
but how was um when you went to actually
riding that lauren and
how did you guys find the balancing how
much to these of these
larger uh history or even like the
mystery of it all
without it overtaking the like the
individual episode storylines
yeah um that's a great question because
because there was uh there was a lot to
balance with it
and um uh yeah i did write a lot of the
history and the lore
first and and it was kind of going in
and kind of
making sure that it didn't overtake too
much of the story it was
it was always tricky kind of calibrating
that part of it because there's so much
there's so many questions
to be answered but but really at the
heart of it we're following
horse through this journey and we always
had to keep in mind this is from her
lens and this and her
her journey emotionally is the most
important thing so that's kind of how we
we um knew when to like lift out stuff
that was
that got too much into the history
because it's always about her and where
she's at
her search for writer um so so i think
prioritizing the emotional
the emotional arc was always most
important for us
well meg it's been a pleasure talking to
you thank you so much and huge
congratulations on the show
thank you thank you so much